why should business care and then
secondly can we kind of unpack a little
bit which businesses should care more or
less and why in terms of which
businesses which sectors have the
greatest impacts on biodiversity and I
put the plus or minus there because
those impacts are not always negative
business can have positive impacts on
biodiversity and ecosystems as well as
negative impacts and of course business
many of them also depend on biodiversity
and ecosystem services and I'll go into
that in a bit more detail broadly
speaking I think we can talk about
internal reasons internal to a business
and external pressures of various kinds
now internal business drivers I've
included consumer preference because
businesses are very focused on meeting
the demands of their customers but also
we need to think about the awareness or
the concern of the managers of a
business themselves because they're part
of this story and they're reading the
the press and other media just as the
rest of us are so they know increasingly
what's going on they're concerned about
it they're also very focused on what
their customers want which may or may
not have something to do with the
environment and they're also concerned
with what their investors want
particularly publicly listed companies
whose shares are sold in the market they
need to pay close attention to what
shareholders are saying in terms of
external pressures there's general
public concern about the environment
increasingly stringent product standards
as well as regulatory requirements so
I'm distinguishing here between
voluntary standards and legal
requirements and more and more
governments are looking to business for
answers to the biodiversity crisis
looking a little bit more closely at
what's going on within business
management and as part of the teeb study
about a year and two months ago we had
the great good fortune to have McKinsey
come to us and say could we do a survey
as a contribution to teeb and
use their contacts in the business world
about 1500 senior executives from around
the world to try and understand what our
business attitudes towards what our
managers attitudes towards biodiversity
and ecosystems and we had to spend a lot
of time trying to translate the the
language of biodiversity and ecosystems
into something that would be meaningful
to these executives hopefully we did
that so that part of the survey was
defining our terms and this is just one
example from the results suggesting that
the the leading reason that these
executives identified biodiversity as a
possible concern to their business was
reputation they want to ensure that they
are seen as good corporate citizens that
they are not seen as the bad guys now
the question is how important is that
really and what are they doing about it
that's another question but certainly
reputation was top of the list of the
reasons that the executives identified
for why they should care but the the
next two down are also interesting one
is the alignment with the company's
business goals mission or values and
there again I think we tend to forget
sometimes that people in business are us
often they're the same they're part of
society they want their companies to be
doing the right thing they want their
business to be contributing to their
their personal goals they want some
alignment or consistency between what
their business is doing and what they
they believe in and I think we shouldn't
discount that as a real driver of change
and thirdly not surprisingly responding
to regulatory requirements many
businesses see increasingly stringent
rules and regulations new laws coming on
the books related to biodiversity and
ecosystems in many different countries
and of course they have to respond to
that
you